have you ever heard of locked-in
syndrome what is it locked-in syndrome
locked in yeah no so I made him watch
movie called a diving bell and the
butterfly and it's a true story about a
guy who was an editor in chief for like
Vogel you have to watch me with great
anyways he gets into a car accident and
then he gets he story he has a traumatic
brain injury so basically all his
thoughts are intact but his body no
longer follows so he he is perfectly
sane and able but his mouth eyes nothing
follows but I don't want to ruin it for
you but everything happened no chance it
this is how it's gonna make you feel
worthless cuz this man unable to do
anything was able to write a book oh
she's with this feat no I'm not seeing
moves with his I want you to get with
one eye
what write an entire book they created a
whole language basically I don't want to
do a racial joke yeah Emily can i I'll
have no I will never be able to write a
book I've never read a book I've never
read of really talk I read I'm glad you
said that I mean I never never said this
out loud before I've never been a
complete bull never I quit a member he
brags about being this like Dostoevsky
expert yeah he has never read a book in
his life that's I've read I never
finished I've read too I've read I've
even gone to the last chapter and just
said yep cuz the movies coming out or
whatever why do I get I give up every
time yeah you know what it might be a my
fear of finishing the book is I know I
won't be as satisfied as I would want to
be like I think that if I finish it in
one second so what baby what what bull
what's the last book that you read I'm
back up I think that's and what was the
last book you attempted to read um
autobiography of a yogi' I mean me I
wouldn't finish that either but I should
have I did it I got through
three-quarters of it true I read a lot
of books and he knows this if I'm not
after the first chapter I'm out I go to
the next sea I keep going and then I
trudged in charge of charge and then
month later I pick it up again and I get
to a point when I go I'm done with that
book can I put it away people redheaded
brain yes you're not a Jew more than I
am you can't you're definitely not any
smarter than I you can't absorb any kind
of information I don't think give me
something and I'll spit it right back
out
go ahead what do you mean give me any
piece of information and I'll harbor it
and give it right back to you what you
because I told you just not you don't
know what go ahead let's try the
experiment all right so what kind of
information
anything that's I don't know anything so
on let's see okay um wharfs son in Star
Trek his name was Alexander perfect now
ask me whatever you need ask me what do
you mean
ask me anything pertaining to that oh
you know about it yeah go ahead
what happened to the mother she got
cancer oh my god no no because it's
it'll get cancer Star Trek that said
that medical theory yes they do war for
the Sun yeah yes it was Alexander's wife
yes II I war I have a son named
Alexander and what's sad about that is
the kid that played Alexander huh was
the blinder oh wow how do you do it I
think he got tattoos on his face
something happy to drugs and he died oh
yeah but he was on he played um Worf son
in Star Trek next generation in season I
think three through six Oh what are four
through six he was the cutest kid he did
a great job and then obviously you know
I was we watching Star Trek next
generation and I got whatever happened
that kid and he's dead that's sad I've
never seen one episode of Star Trek of
any of them nope and Game of Thrones you
ever seen Game of Thrones
wait you watch nothing what do you read
it so you don't read you don't watch
these thing sometimes I said sometimes I
sit and I stare at my couch I do I said
I Sarah my couch I go what are you
looking at I jump on it and I go he
watches a blue
mixology tapes I write my old my first
second yeah every every show that he's
on he was what I do i watch i watch i
watch whatever i've done i've only what
i won't and i cut it so it's my scenes i
have an editor cut just my scenes so i
just watch me and then what I only read
stuff from my journal when I was in
junior high I only read my journal over
and over and over and over I could
repeat with you easily right now mom and
dad are [ __ ] yeah so what so what so
what I am Who I am
I'm gonna listen to Pearl Jam Jeremy in
the room as loud as I yeah yeah yeah
that was me
[Music]